Transcription: Lucy Harford
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
J’avoue que
je me fais tout le temps avoir.
Mais vraiment par tout ce qui se passe.
Je suis le premier nigaud.
Et un truc qui vraiment, vraiment
m’arrive tous les jours, c’est ça.
Dès que ça arrive,
je peux plus me concentrer.
Un truc se passe chez moi, j’ai envie
de comprendre ce qu’il se passe.
Et donc je me suis dit,
« Est-ce que je suis le seul
dans ce cas-là ? »
Donc, j’ai demandé autour de moi.
Vraiment à tout le monde.
Et je suis le seul
à qui ca arrive sur Slack.
Mais tout ce qui est Messenger,
Snap ou WhatsApp,
tout le monde a la même situation.
Et je me suis dit,
il y a peut être quelque chose derrière.
Et je me suis mis à creuser.
Et quand on creuse,
on comprend rapidement
que c’est la manière dont on est câblé
qui nous impose, on va dire,
à un certain moment,
d’agir comme on le fait.
Et ça s’appelle le biais cognitif.
Et le biais dans lequel je tombe,
et la plupart d’entre nous,
on tombe lorsque ça s’arrive,
c’est le gap de curiosité.
Le gap de curiosité,
c’est l’espace entre ce qu’on veut avoir
et ce qu’on a actuellement.
Et pour le combler,
on va aller sur l’application
sur le jeu ou la notification.
Et donc là, on se dit,
« Mais si je suis câblé comme ça,
et que je suis un peu victime
de mon biais cognitif,
est-ce vraiment moi qui ai choisi ? »
Donc, en tant que product major,
je vais me dire, « Super, les utilisateurs
sont revenus sur mon produit.
Donc la rétention va peut-être augmenter
et c’est parfait. »
Mais la vraie question à se poser,
c’est : l’utilisateur, avait-il besoin
de revenir sur le produit ?
Et c’est là qu’on ne peut pas forcément
jouer et changer
ce qui se passe dans les entreprises.
Mais on peut commencer
à comprendre les mécanismes,
et si on comprend les mécanismes,
on peut mieux choisir.
Donc, là, j’ai une mauvaise habitude.
Mais qu’est-ce qu’une habitude ?
Quand on fait des recherches,
on comprend rapidement qu’en fait
une habitude, c’est défini par ça.
Il y a un indice, visuel,
sonore, contextuel :
je vois quelque chose,
et j’ai envie d’y aller,
et l’envie provoque une réaction.
Une fois qu’on a cette réaction,
on a la récompense.
Et toutes nos habitudes
sont définies de cette manière.
Donc qu’est-ce qui se passe
dans mon quotidien ?
Où sont les habitudes ?
Elles sont bonnes ou mauvaises ?
Un truc que j’ai remarqué, c’est que
chaque fois que je suis dans le Métro,
j’ai envie de sortir mon téléphone.
Et pourquoi ?
Au début, je comprenais mal.
Je me suis arrêté,
j’ai fait un pas en arrière,
je me suis dit, « Mais attends,
j’ai pris mon téléphone
parce que quelqu’un d’autre
a pris le sien.
Mais j’ai rien à faire sur mon téléphone.
Juste par réflexe,
envie de le déverrouiller.
Donc là, on comprend l’action,
mais qu’est-ce qui me fait la faire ?
Par exemple, il y a différentes catégories
et différents éléments composants
qui définissent l’action.
Quelqu’un bien plus intelligent que moi
et bien plus sympathique,
B.J. Fogg, le fondateur
et le faiseur de milliards de Stanford,
a créé ces schémas pour expliquer pourquoi
le comportement fait certaines choses.
On voit que le comportement est
défini par la motivation et la capacité.
Moi, ma motivation, pour mon téléphone,
compliqué à la changer,
mais ma capacité,
c’est le fait que je puisse
prendre mon téléphone assez simplement.
On voit que lorsque on allie les deux,
je vais agir.
Et là, je me rappelle d’un truc
que j’ai lu en science.
Ça va justifier mes études de science.
C’est les frictions.
Si je veux inciter
ou retirer un élément, une action,
je joue sur les frictions.
Les frictions, c’est le nombre d’obstacles
qu’on rencontre
avant de faire quelque chose.
Donc, dans mon cas,
j’ai envie de retirer cette action
parce que c’est une mauvaise habitude,
et j’essaie de rajouter des frictions.
Peut être au niveau 1,
au niveau de l’indice,
mais bon, je ne vais pas
fermer les yeux dans les transports
ou je vais pas jeter
tous les téléphones de la rame.
Sinon, je vais moi aussi
finir en dehors de la rame.
L’envie, une fois qu’elle est là,
compliqué de la retirer.
Et par contre l’action :
mon téléphone était dans ma poche.
Donc je pourrais faire quelque chose.
Mais ce que je fais aujourd’hui,
et vous allez me croire fou,
je mets mon téléphone dans mon sac
qui est lui-même dans une autre poche.
Comme ça, je le prends pas
parce que j’ai juste la flemme.
À chaque fois, je le prends,
je dois le remettre et c’est trop chiant.
Et là , on voit rapidement la flemme.
On se dit que la flemme,
c’est quelque chose de commun, de courant.
Mais en fait,
innover, c’est maximiser la flemme.
Aujourd’hui, lorsqu’on voit
toutes nos applications,
tous les produits qu’on utilise,
on comprend que
c’est la maximisation de la flemme
qui les a créés.
C’est pas forcément une mauvaise chose,
au contraire.
Mais on n’est pas les premiers
à l’avoir compris.
Toutes les plus grosses sociétés
l’ont compris,
et lorsqu’elles cherchent
à faire une action,
elles vont regarder
les points de friction
pour les réduire ou les augmenter.
Mais est-ce qu’elles vont les réduire
et les augmenter dans notre intérêt ?
Là est la vraie réflexion
qu’on doit avoir.
Chaque minute,
on a un demi million de tweets,
puis deux millions de snaps,
quatre million de vues sur YouTube
et un million de swipes.
Toutes ces applications
réduisent les frictions.
Mais pourquoi ?
Le truc, c’est que leur intérêt
n’est pas aligné avec le nôtre.
Il faut qu'on passe un maximum
de temps sur la plateforme.
C’est comme ça qu’une minute
devient 15 minutes, puis 20, voire plus.
Et ça, on peut se dire que c’est
parce qu’ils ont pensé à l’utilisateur
parce qu’ils rendent l’expérience
plus rapide, plus efficace, plus simple,
mais pas forcément.
Parce qu’il se trouve que parfois
ils utilisent des dark patterns.
Les dark patterns, c’est tout ce qui
est désaligné avec notre intérêt.
L’exemple de la petite carte Amazon
qui s’enregistre automatiquement
pour le prochain achat.
Comme ça, il n’y a pas de friction.
L’exemple de la vidéo qui s’enchaîne
parce que c’est automatique,
c’est plus simple.
Mais ça, c’est parce que
c’est dans leur intérêt.
Leur business model est calqué
sur notre concentration
et sur le fait
qu’on se concentre sur leur publicité.
Quand on voit que les deux
plus grosses sociétés de la planète
font plus de 80% de leur chiffre
d’affaires à partir de notre attention,
on se dit qu’il y a un truc
qui peut gêner.
Et en fait, les conséquences réelles,
elles sont là,
c’est que chaque jour,
on déverrouille environ
toutes les 12 minutes notre téléphone
et on met 25 minutes à reprendre
notre niveau de concentration.
Vous voyez le dilemme ?
Toutes les 12 minutes,
on se déconcentre,
et toutes les 25 minutes, on essaie
de reprendre notre concentration.
Si ça met 25 minutes à reprendre
la concentration, mais 12 minutes
pour justement être interrompu,
quand est-ce qu’on se concentre ?
Et le pire dans tout ça,
c’est que ne serait-ce que
la présence d’un téléphone
nous déconcentre.
Mais en vrai, il y a de l’espoir
parce qu’on a déjà les outils.
Le génie est libéré de la lampe,
mais c’est tant mieux parce qu’on permet
de faire de nouvelles choses.
Mais aujourd’hui,
le seul souci qu’on avait,
c’est qu’on jouait un jeu dont
on ne maîtrisait pas les règles.
Maintenant, on comprend les mécanismes,
on sait quoi faire.
Dans votre quotidien,
ce que j’aimerais bien que vous fassiez,
c’est que vous prenez un pas en arrière
et que vous regardez un peu
ce qui se passe,
voir les habitudes, les définir :
l’indice, l’envie,
la réponse et la récompense.
Une fois qu’on la voit, on peut définir
si c’est bonne ou mauvaise.
Et si c’est une mauvaise,
où peut-on ajouter de la friction ?
Si c’est une bonne,
où peut-on le retirer ?
Parce que s’il y a un truc à retenir,
c’est que comprendre,
c’est pouvoir choisir.
Merci.